non vraiment bon soir alors je vous
présente nos amis donc jean luc
mélenchon je les sénateurs par rien vous
êtes en train de sénateur est le neveu
de l'ancien président de la république
vous avez quand même pas mal mallaury
nataf
j'ai complètement changé de vie qui
maintenant fait de la médication
toujours sans culottes et du théâtre
voilà kad et olivier donc monsieur voix
la
liste linda hardy élan calendrier à
lorient d'un drap blanc on peut dire que
vous êtes passé sept ans de votre saison
de votre vie avec marguerite duras et on
va essayer de voir comment s'est passée
cette histoire que vous raconter dans un
livre qui est paru chez pauvert et qui
s'appelle cet amour-là zoom mon garçon
zoum zoum zoum un garçon
bien alors je vous ai préparé un petit
sampler
l'enfant
faut dire que marguerite avait quand
même des faits de vote rennais de 38 ans
donc non moins que ça - que ça combien
j'aime ça moix alors votre vrai nom et
yann andréa tziganes le met vous êtes né
en 52 le 24 décembre juste avant minuit
c'est une sorte de jésus
vous étiez étudiant en philo à caen
et un jour vous lisez les petits chevaux
de tarquinia de marguerite duras et vous
êtes fasciné par la lecture de ce livre
très belle histoire ça et vous
abandonner tous les autres livres pour
lire seulement des livres de marguerite
duras vous rencontrez duras dans un
débat je raconte je vous pose pas de
question que c'est une histoire sera
votre bouquin il le sait donc je vais
vite vous rencontrez duras dans un débat
à caen où elle vient à l'occasion de la
projection
d'ignacio cinéma lux et vous lui
demander une dédicace et son adresse à
partir de là vous lui écrivait
et comme d'autres d'ailleurs mais mais
vous vous l'écrivez sans cesse sans
arrêt et sans attendre de réponse et
sans recevoir de courrier non plus de la
part de marguerite duras et un jour elle
vous envoie un livre l'homme assis dans
le couloir peut être surpris de recevoir
un lit parce que vous avez jamais rien
reçu de marguerite duras vous cessez lui
écrire et là elle vous envoie un mot et
en 1981 la rencontre la deuxième
rencontre enfin lieu vous allez aux
roches noires à trouville prendre un
verre et vous ne partirez plus elle
avait 66 ans vous deviez 28 et vous ne
vous quittera plus jusqu'à la mort de
marguerite duras est-ce que vous est-ce
que vous avez expliqué pourquoi elle
nous avait jamais écrit pendant cinq ans
j'ai pas de réponse est la seule réponse
était de jeu viennent et que je reste
donc là le mécanisme est en mars était
le mécanisme de prise de possession par
un écrivain d'un personnage personnages
qu'on s'entend
alors à partir de là elle décide de tout
ce que vous faites ce que vous ce que
vous mangez c'est ça oui comment ça se
passe et c'était vous étiez je suis pas
soumis quand même c'était dans quel état
d'esprit vous étiez par rapport à elle
vous acceptez facilement espèce de
dictature intime non dictature si les
mauves ou non non c'était pas l'esprit
non mais c'est son serviteur
marguerite bien si on avait l'habitude
des boys et les colonies oui d'indochine
fallait alors qu'un serviteur fidèle
très oui elle aussi ouais c'était pas
facile de vivre avec elle parce qu'elles
n'étaient pas toujours toujours facile à
vivre s'est mis c'est rien de le dire
qu'un peu avare d x ecône on y voit l
fénié de deux soupçonnés de vous
soupçonne être avec elle pour l'argent
et elles vous disais vous n'aurez rien
ben oui c'est ce qui est arrivé bah vous
avez quand même 10 % des droits d'auteur
oui enfin oui
non bonjour
onze jours a commencé
et la danse qui est extraordinaire dans
votre histoire ils gagnent c'est que
vous devenez un personnage de duras
d'ailleurs yann andréa steiner et c'est
une heure c'était tout faire en même
temps c'est un peu un vivacom comme si
c'était ma vie va arriver mais on a
quand même vécu mais vous vouliez partir
certaines fois vous arriviez pas vous
reveniez toujours oui
bonjour je n'ai pas possible de vous
séparer qua non elle vous faisait
recherché aussi oui enfin je n'ai pas
loin
on se dit une force d'amour comme ça on
aime ou peut-être qu'on l'a pas connu
qu'on aimerait connaître sur le plan
humain c'est terrifiant c'est un monstre
comment vous attends attends je parlais
une vampirisation pareil d'un autre par
l'eau dans l'amour il me semble que dans
la nourrir quelque chose on donne on
reçoit et que font les égalités et vous
vous êtes vous démarrez vous vous dites
vous-même
vous jette dehors dit on te fout dehors
est sûrs virale arrive souvent vous
savez
bah oui c'est pas ça du noir est
blessant mais non
mais oui sa part été mais c'est terrible
pour tout le monde dans tous les cas les
histoires vous ça vous a rendu heureux
non c'est pas le cas d'être heureux
ici c'est l'amour c'est pas pour être
heureux non parce que d'amour c'est pas
seulement ça c'était autre chose cette
année le livre à écrire la relation avec
elles au fond c'était ça ça passait pas
ce qu'ils avaient à écrire les films à
faire les pièces de théâtre et vous
aimiez une personne ou une institution
de toute personne à personne donnant une
personne et ben c'est une personne qui
écrivait justement ça pose la question
de qui est qui et comment ça comment ça
se passe mais de 2 degré d'intimité avec
n est pas très
vous appelez vous l'appeliez pas
marguerite vous l'appelez comment je ne
souhaite pas vous tutoyez pas par
exemple moi nommé louis ah bon voulez
vous voyez oui à sa durée saison donc
pendant 16 ans de l'été son ami son
assistant son chauffeur et viviez avec
elle sans rien faire de enfin si j'avais
beaucoup à faire avant d'être avec elle
c'est
indeed vous raconter l'anecdote tous
quelqu'un vous dit qu'est ce que vous
faites il vous répond je ne fais rien et
les le dit très bien c'est très bien et
vous ne faites rien ouais c'est vrai non
je faisais rien au fond oui j'étais là
vous pensez que vous étiez celui qu'elle
attendait pour
rechercher sa vérité puisqu'elle est sur
la recherche de la vérité tatoué
peut-être alors en mars 96 elle elmer et
vous dites je suis presque mort avec
elle j'ai honte de survivre à cette mort
donc c'est un amour quand même très très
très très fort vous installer en face de
l'endroit où vivait avec elle à paris
cette fois donc dans un studio ou
partager vos deux valises la tête d'un
studio et vous sortez plus vous cherchez
à vous tuer vous y arrivez pas dont vous
en déduisez voulait pas vraiment vous
tuer
vous appelez votre mère qui vous qui
vous ramène chez elle
mais vous restez chez votre mère
quelques mois vous rentrer à paris
quelques mois plus tard le jour de la
sainte marguerite oui hélas vous
renfermez dans ce studio et vous écrivez
donc ce livre magnifique c'est à morlaàs
qu'étant une bouleversant et voilà et
maintenant alors qu'est ce qui se passe
je suis là maintenant je veux dire c est
ce que vous avez le sentiment depuis la
mort de faim depuis la mort de
marguerite duras mais depuis la
publication de ce livre que tout est dit
que la messe est dite vous jouer les
prolongations ou est ce que vous espérez
que la vie vous apportera d'autres
choses pas forcément puisque je vis un
jury mais les choses aussi forte vous
mais peut-être je sais pas vous n'êtes
pas pessimiste par rapport à ça vous
pensez pas que votre histoire et votre
histoire est derrière vous mais non
justement le livre dit qu'elle est
présente l'histoire et que c'est pas
parce que quelqu'un est mort continuent
à lui écrire voilà ouais alors
aujourd'hui comme je disais tout à
l'heure et 10% des droits d'auteur et
son exécuteur littéraire des problèmes
dont on va parler ici parce que c'est la
cuisine c'est le cas de le dire
d'ailleurs la cuisine éditoriale avec
son fils jean mascolo justement sur un
bouquin qui s'appelle la cuisine de
marguerite alors j'ai noté 3,4 phrase de
marguerite duras
paris durera vous êtes dirigé le monde
entier voudraient être à votre place
oui oui vous pouvez vous penser que oui
ni non revenons pas tout le monde
peut-être pas on construit nice
comment tom cruise
et quand elle vous disais c'est pas moi
vous aimez c'est duras
oui alors
à votre avis
manon s'étaient mélangés
c'était pas mal quand même de décrocher
sa way régime humidité
bon maintenant de la merci beaucoup donc
je rappelle le titre de votre livre cet
amour là chez pauvert merci voilà et
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de 1h10
tube abonnez vous je m'étais un peu ce
bleu